hello everyone and welcome to a game so
many of you have requested a little
already even though it was
just played moments ago i just woke up
had a cup of coffee checked my phone and
uh
everyone was suggesting for me to show
uh one of the games
of the match it's devakipas
women women's grandmaster and an
international master
and there was a lot of us about the
devakipas in the past
month i think i'm not completely
familiar with the subject if anyone has
like uh you know something that we can
read and that's uh
you know very concise and very short
please add it in the description below
so i can pin it for everyone else to see
but here this is basically organized
on the youtube channel of dedicate to
show the world that uh devakipas is the
uh well
the chess player that he claims that he
is so this is the first game of their
match
it's a rapid match 10 minutes per
players per player zero seconds
increment
uh so let's check it out and then uh we
will see if we're going to show some
more games i don't know if you guys are
are interested in that so without
further ado let's check it out
uh uh pass opens uh with
d4 uh we have knight to f6 by irene
uh knight to f3 and now e6 we have e3
and now
b6 preparing to fianchetto the light
square bishop the so called you super
rubenstein system
uh we have bishop to e2 and now bishop
to b7
i think catering the light square bishop
definitely makes sense we have knight b
to d2 and
bishop to e7 uh ready to castle the the
king
uh we have a3 now and c5 striking in the
center
we have c4 grabbing more space in the
center and here both players castle so
castles castles
uh and now d5 so everything perfectly
fine here
uh we have knight to e5 and excellent
outpost for the white knight and now
knight b to d7 ready to challenge that
knight so f4
uh cementing that knight on e5 and rook
to c8
we have bishop to f3 and now you have to
be very careful because the bishop on b7
is undefended so you can't to do any
captures for the moment
but knight to e4 irene is very happy
with this knight here
and should white ever capture then this
pawn comes to e4 and it's gonna be
uh well sort of a bone in in white's
throat so here
b3 strengthening the c four pawn also
preparing bishop to b2
uh you should always be careful when
playing a move like this because uh well
if the position opens up and somehow
queen captures and d4 happens uh you
might uh
you might lose that rook uh here it's
not possible because for example even if
you start opening up the position for
example captures captures and captures
uh after f captures you have this d
captures and c for threatening to
capture this and win the rook
uh it doesn't work however because
knight captures knight and now the queen
defends the pawn you've just lost a
piece but you have to be
uh careful of such things when playing
b3
so here it doesn't work uh irene goes
knight d to f6
strengthens the knight here and now
bishop to b2
continuing development we have knight
captures on d2
uh getting rid of this knight and
preparing to promote this knight into a
monster knight we have queen captures
and the knights to e4 now
attacking the queen here queen to d3 and
now
even f6 here it's perfectly fine uh
because now the knight gets kicked away
so knight g4
and queen to e8 now preparing to bring
the queen into the game also one of the
uses of this f6 move
uh rook eight to c1 and here comes queen
to g6 and here the situation on the
clock is uh
deva has some 3 minutes and 40 seconds
on the clock whereas irene has six
minutes on the clock so he has to figure
something
uh we have h3 and now comes
rook f2d8 the rooks are now nicely
placed on the c and d
file the position is ready to be open
and here
king to h2 sort of improving the
position of the king but not really
because here h5 pushes back the knight
and now
the problem is uh if you uh accept
black's idea and go back knight to f2
then black just goes
into a monster capture fest and just
trades everything and gets a
well sort of a winning position for
example captures on d4
captures on d4 and now e5 uh offering
further captures we have f captures on
e5
queen g3 check king to g1 and now knight
g5
threatening knight captures an f3 check
uh king h1 and queen to h2 checkmate
so queen f5 the only move that guards
the bishop and now
knight captures an f3 queen captures
queen captures g
captures f captures on e5 bishop
captures now d
captures in c4 rook characters on c4 we
have captures captures and
after this captures on f3 we get this
position where it's a bishop pair
against
bishop and the knight both players still
having their rooks but white's spawn
structure is completely messed up
and the black should be able to win this
game so this is kind of if
if black goes back after this h5 move
and it's not pleasant going back you're
down on the clock you're
having a worse position so instead here
uh deva plays
f5 and this is uh well this is uh uh
like nepal played yesterday this is full
barbarian mode uh
just you know go going all out e
captures on f5 was played
now knights to f2 and now bishop to d6
with
check we have king the g1 and now feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for irene
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those who were able to do it
congratulations on finding that uh queen
g3
is just unstoppable and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
that's the stuff queen g3 now the knight
is here queen to h2 will be checkmate so
the knight needs to move but if the
knight moves uh that's just it you can't
move the knight
just anywhere because this is still
checkmate the knight here covers the f2
square
so unfortunately for deva you have to
capture on e4 but that means you just
lose a piece because after d captures on
e4 now both the queen and the bishop are
under attack
queen has to move and now e captures an
f3 complete annihilation
uh we have d5 blocking this dark square
bishop but now
queen to h2 check king f2 and queen
capture sanji
to check and it was in this position
where we've reached the position from
the thumbnail that they will keep us
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here once the king moves
we're just gonna keep gobbling up pieces
if king he won just bishop g3 checking
d1
queen captures an e1 that's uh a full
rook king c2 queen captures on h3
and uh black is just just up too much
material up a full
up a full rook up a bishop uh so many
past pawns here
ready to you know become new queens this
is of course completely winning
so after uh this um g captur a queen
captures on g2 with
check uh they will keep us resigned and
the first game goes to are you in
sukhandar
and well we'll see what happens in the
rest of the match if you guys are
interested in some other games but if
you want to see all of these games live
at the first link in the description
below you can
watch all of them live so i just wanted
to
you know share that with you uh so yeah
that's the game i hope you guys enjoyed
it
uh i would like to thank sebastian baum
john king uh conrado zagabrian scoop
donner coin and steven rind for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent start of your week